hello to you ms sturgeon thanks for
joining us also we put it to labor this
morning about the promise or hope for a
second referendum in the form of lisa
nandy she said you've got some brassneck
what would you say in response
i'm a democrat i was elected first
minister my government was elected at
just over a year ago on a proposition to
give people in scotland the choice of
independence recognizing at the
significant changes that have taken
place in the uk since scotland last had
that opportunity recognising the fact
that westminster with governments we
don't vote for here in scotland taking
us in the wrong direction there is a
majority clear majority in the scottish
parliament behind that proposition so
it's a matter of democracy that people
should have the right to choose and then
whether or not people choose
independence or not is a matter not for
politicians whether that's me ben
wallace or lisa and andy that's a matter
for the scottish people and i suspect if
my political opponents
were
actually believed what they say that
scotland doesn't want independence then
they would not be so desperate to block
scotland's opportunity to have that
choice
well he said in 2014 as we all know that
this was a once in a generation um
referendum i wonder what the clear
mandate is that you're talking about i
was looking in the daily record saying
that there have been 23 polls in the
last year and yes has led in only three
of them
well let me take head on this once in
the generation point in in 2014 at the
last referendum now almost a decade ago
those of us arguing for independence yes
said to people make sure you don't lose
this opportunity we might never get the
chance again but no politician can stand
in the way of democracy democracy is not
a single fixed moment in time people in
a democracy have the right to change
their minds if circumstances change and
nobody can argue that circumstances have
not changed since 2014. you know back
then scotland was told we would lose
european union membership if we voted
for independence and now we're out of
the european union because we didn't
become independent that's happened
against our will we were told the
prospect of boris johnson ever becoming
prime minister was ridiculous
that may have been true but it is
nevertheless a reality now and yet again
we have a westminster government pulling
us in the wrong direction creating the
worst cost of living crisis in the
developed world almost because of brexit
and scotland is expected to just say
well you know there's nothing we can do
about that so this is about democratic
choice it's not up to me whether
scotland becomes independent but it is
up to me to fulfill the promise i made
to people in scotland and was elected on
to offer people that choice and you can
quote opinion polls i can quote opinion
polls back at you but what i'm actually
standing on is the outcome of a
democratic election uh there is a
stronger mandate
for an independent referendum in the
scottish parliament than there ever was
for a brexit referendum in the uk
parliament a majority of msps in the
scottish parliament support a referendum
so if we are a democracy then that
should be respected and then of course
it is up to people in scotland whether
they vote for independence or against
independence that is how to resolve
issues in any democracy
i was speaking to the government
minister yesterday and he said chris
phelp he was saying that what you should
be doing is uh concentrating more on
drug deaths in scotland and we took the
opportunity to look at the figures drug
deaths in scotland 35 times worse than
they are in france 15 times worse than
they are in germany that's where you
should be focused
we are focused on that i want to come on
in a second to the the link between
independence and some of these
day-to-day issues that are priorities
for people but we are focused on these
things every
single day um there are
long
reasons with deep roots in terms of
scotland's drug death situation but it
is unacceptable so we're investing at
250 million pounds in better treatment
faster treatment better rehabilitation
better community support to turn that
around i've appointed a dedicated
minister to lead this work we are taking
this seriously of course one of the
things that there is across party
support around in scotland and we're
trying to find a way to do it is to
establish something that has been shown
to work in other countries which is safe
consumption facilities we're unable or
have been unable to to do that
straightforwardly through a change in
legislation because the misuse of drugs
act is reserved to the westminster
parliament so i'm not seeking to escape
responsibility on the the drugs death
issue but even on that the fact that the
scottish parliament is not independent
it has real implications but finally kay
on this issue of it's a choice between
focusing on day-to-day priorities or
focusing on independence independence is
about better equipping scotland to deal
with and navigate the challenges we face
we're struggling with a cost of living
crisis right now which is worse in the
uk than it is in any other g7 country
precisely because of brexit something
imposed on scotland against our will my
government is investing at almost three
billion pounds a year to help people
with the cost of living we've
established a scottish child payment
doesn't exist anywhere else in the uk
and yet as we do that we have a
chancellor at the stroke of his pen
pushing more children into poverty by
taking money away from university has
been rising independence is about giving
okay child poverty has changed scotland
a million people on the nhs waiting list
let me can i can i take on that and can
i take it i'll come to the nhs in a
second yeah
the child poverty point
i need to address because firstly child
poverty in scotland is the lowest
of all of the four uk uh nations i think
in the last
statistics and that is because of the
action we're taking we established a
scottish child payment 20 pounds a week
to the lowest income families no other
government in the uk has done that but
child poverty is rising because so many
of the decisions that determine that are
taken at westminster so cuts to benefits
at 20 pounds a week being taken away
from low-income families in the
universal credit claw back so that's an
argument for equipping the scottish
parliament with all of the powers that
countries across the world who are
already independent take for granted and
you know we published analysis just a
couple of weeks ago showing that a range
of countries comparable to scotland many
smaller than us uh most of them without
the resources that scotland okay talk to
me about the energy better economically
and socially because they have the
powers of independence on the nhs the
nhs again waiting times in the nhs in
scotland accident emergency for example
shorter and in many ways doing better
than the other countries in the uk nhs
staff the highest paid in scotland in
the whole of the uk we have significant
problems in our national health service
largely because of the covert pressures
they are not unique to scotland but we
are supporting the nhs into and through
recovery but one of the things we are
struggling with is a situation where
westminster governments and its whales
in northern ireland are suffering from
this as well as are parts of england
budgets that are being cut by a
chancellor
who is pursuing austerity politics
rather than investing so we will be
better able to deal with
support for our public services if we
are in charge of all
of the levers that effectively determine
the environment and the financial
situation that we are operating within
worst ever scores in maths and science
in 20 years
sorry i didn't hear your question worst
ever scores in maths and science in 20
years
we're again like all countries we are
focused on these uh challenges but you
take the attainment gap for example at
narrowing again like most countries
exacerbated by covid but if you take the
attainment gap in access to university
which of course is a key measure
of how
schools are are performing often we have
an independent commissioner for fair
access to universities who in his report
just a couple of weeks ago said that
scotland was leading the way in the uk
that what we had done was an unequivocal
success and we are narrowing in fact
we're meeting our targets to narrow the
gap between the young people from
deprived communities and wealthier
communities in terms of the
opportunities to get to university so
using the powers we have we're not
shying away from challenges each and
every day we focus on these challenges
but my argument is we will be better
able to meet those challenges and to
meet the wider challenges that scotland
in common with countries around the
world face if we don't have one hand
tied behind our back and too often are
being pulled in the wrong direction by
westminster governments that we don't
vote for
but it's up to the supreme court isn't
it and they are unlikely to find in your
favor for a second referendum well
i mean i think i think we should allow
the supreme court to do
its job and i respect the rule of law
it's not the prerogative of government
referendum that's the point isn't it and
that's what they'll find well sorry
that the whole point the whole point of
making is that that is contested but you
cannot say that as a statement of fact
because it hasn't been judicially
determined that's what we are
through the decision of the lord
advocate in scotland are seeking to get
at judicial determination of that point
it wouldn't be necessary of course if
boris johnson and the uk government
simply respected democracy and agreed
the process to put a referendum beyond
legal doubt but i'm doing the
responsible thing a referendum has to be
lawful i'm not like boris johnson who's
of course breaching international law
with his actions on the northern ireland
protocol i respect the rule of law which
is why we are taking the path that i set
out yesterday that's the responsible
thing to do but i also respect democracy
scottish democracy cannot be a prisoner
of boris johnson or any uk prime
minister at the people of scotland must
have the right to choose it is then
entirely up to the people of scotland
what that choice is but trying to simply
block democracy as
unionist politicians are doing simply
because they fear the verdict of the
scottish people is not democratic it's
not acceptable and ultimately it is
simply not sustainable
always a pleasure miss sturgeon thank
you